hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my arrow episode 2 video
there's also been a lot of DC movie news
so I'll cover that too after I get
through arrow stuff we got a good look
at one of the brand new characters
comodo for this season we found out
where the-- has been and we got a big
teaser for another giant arc that's
gonna go across the first half of this
season careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet but
starting with top 5 moments here we go
number 5 team arrow grieves so this was
definitely probably one of the most cry
worthy episodes of arrow ever obviously
everyone's grieving for Sarah she's
definitely dead they buried her put her
in the ground a lot of you guys have
been asking me about the Lazarus Pit no
I don't think they're gonna use that
obviously they want to advance laurels
Black Canary story arc and they can't do
that while Sarah is still alive I think
the speed with which they killed Sarah
tells you about how fast they want to
advance that Laurel storyline obviously
at the end of the episode she was
staring at the jacket there's a lot of
storylines being teased but I think it's
gonna be a while before Laurel gets
there it could happen as soon as the
mid-season finale it might take to the
end of the season aside from the horror
of having to stare at Sarah's dead body
all of team arrow is trying to grieve in
their own way
Oliver obviously not doing so well at it
all of the malarkey that he's speaking
about being a leader is what gives
Felicity the bump to go work for Ray
Palmer for those wondering about the Ray
Palmer stuff there's nothing sexual
going on there he just wants her to come
work for him just because she's really
smart number four Felicity goes to work
for Ray Palmer Felicity is going to be
the bridge between team arrow and Ray
Palmer obviously Ray Palmer at some
point is going to have to cross paths
with the arrow even though he kind of
did in the episode did anyone else catch
the Blue Queen industries logo - that
was pretty surreal in the background the
other really interesting thing about Ray
Palmer that's only been teased in his
character description is that he's
hiding you know some sort of lost that
he's suffered that he hasn't told anyone
about I think his wife died under
unfortunate circumstances and just like
Malcolm Merlyn turned to the League of
Assassins Ray Palmer is gonna turn to
fighting crime to try and turn it into
something positive
Ray Palmer just happens to be a tech
genius billionaire so hopefully at some
point we'll get to see him kick some
butt
the title of the midseason finale
there's two parts to it is arrow vs
flash that's the flash episode the arrow
side of that is called The Brave and the
bold so I'm assuming Ray Palmer is gonna
get tied up in some sort of team arrow
plot at that point whether or not he
learns all of her secret identity before
that remains to be seen number three
Laurel wants to fight back so this is
all very clearly part of her arc to
becoming Black Canary
that's why Sarah had to die her death is
the call to action that Laurel needed
and during that burial scene obviously
Diggle said that they would name the
baby Sara to honor her memory but Laurel
will probably take on the mantle of
Black Canary to honor her memory as well
I thought that was a big easter egg no
one will remember her name so I'm going
to honor her by taking on the mantle
something you guys should get really
excited about though is Laurel in
training obviously we saw Thea training
at the end of the episode the same kind
of thing is gonna happen with Laurel
don't know exactly how it's gonna go
down but we do know that Wildcat is
gonna be part of team arrow at some
point at least he's gonna be on the show
having scenes with Laurel so they're
probably gonna be doing some training we
only saw him briefly in that first
episode fighting in the boxing ring he
was you know team Wildcat so we'll see
how he and Laurel end up crossing paths
eventually but in the comics Wildcat is
very famous for having trained several
the big Justice League a listers how to
fight at least the human ones and no I
do not think he's gonna be wearing the
classic Wildcat costume I am really
happy to see Katie Cassidy get this big
story arc I wasn't a huge fan of her in
season 2 I think that was kind of the
point though like she had hit rock
bottom before she could work her way
back up to the top but if you look at
Katie Cassidy
she actually has like some serious guns
on her right now like it's crazy how
much she's been working out I think in
terms of filming their past episode 10
or their filming episode 10 right about
now so she's just gonna get bigger and
bigger until they get to the finale
Oliver doesn't really look like he has
the mental capacity to handle training
someone right now so I think that's why
Laurel is gonna turn to Wildcat for
training we also can't forget about her
pulling the trigger on that gun she
actually tried to shoot Komodo she tried
to kill him
of all the big moments I would say that
was one of the bigger WTF was her
pulling the trigger she would have been
a murderer had Oliver not had the
poor sight to take the bullets out of
the gun number two meet Komodo he's
being played by Matt ward but in the
comics he's an enemy of Oliver Queen's
obviously the show's doing something a
little bit different with him he seems a
little bit more ambiguous like he's a
hired assassin he's just not like
straight up trying to kill team arrow
somebody hired him to kill people that
are behind the Star City development
that's ray Palmer's big plan to
revitalize the city
aside from Malcolm Merlyn there are only
a couple other people on the show that
we know about a couple of bad characters
that might want to derail that big
development one is obviously vertigo cuz
he's pushing drugs all over the city the
other is Ray shot ghoul we don't really
know what the character is gonna be
doing on the show yet so it's a little
early to start throwing him into the mix
Komodo for now obviously is not dead but
he will show up again this season but
just to be clear I do not think that
he's working for Malcolm Merlyn in my
number one moment
team arrow buries Sara's body this is
like the moment of eulogy obviously
Oliver made a big deal about not
grieving earlier in the episode he is
grieving now like that's especially with
the last moments of the episode were
about when he was getting ready to
contact via and he even said it himself
I don't want to die down here I'll be
really interested to see how he tries to
dig himself out of that emotional hole
obviously he's turning to Thea first but
because of her story arc this season
that's obviously going to be causing
some big big problems for him that's
actually the title of the next episode
corto Maltese he and Roy are gonna be
going down there to try and find her
just like Tommy went to Hong Kong to
find Oliver it was meant to be a serious
scene but it was really fun seeing Colin
O'Donnell he actually appeared at Comic
Con with Stephen Amell like Stephen
Amell was doing a regular old comic-con
panel just by himself
Colin O'Donnell happened to be there and
just sat on the panel with him it was
awesome just a couple of rows just like
old times the important thing to
remember about Sarah's death is that
it's not over like obviously there are
going to be consequences you know Oliver
is going to visit consequences on
whoever did this to her he's gonna find
out who that is Sarah also had other
people in her life that are gonna want
some justice namely Nyssa al Ghul Oliver
specifically invoked the League of
Assassins during the episode he said
Sarah had been trained by some of the
best killers in the world obviously
talking about the league
I don't know that it'll be next week's
episode but eventually Nyssa al Ghul
will be back on the show and obviously
Rashad Ghul will come to the real big
question now is who killed Sara and why
I think it was probably somebody inside
the League of Assassins but I don't
think it was Rachel Ghul himself and I
don't think it was Miss al Ghul that
doesn't leave a whole lot other people
it's possible that there's a villain
that they haven't announced yet and
right now I think they've only written
up to like episode 12 or 13 so there's
still like 10 episodes after that so
there's just a whole lot of characters
they haven't decided on yet there's also
Amanda Waller to remember she ordered
Oliver to kill his best friend Tommy
Merlyn it's possible that she's also
behind Sara's death like she ordered the
hit like a Suicide Squad member to kill
her but let me know what was your
favorite moment from the episode and who
do you think killed Sara
overall I gave the episode a solid
b-plus just for doing such a great job
of mourning a dead character they really
do go out on a limb when they do
episodes like this there are big Downers
I mean it's a very depressing episode
very depressing subject they're so good
at doing actions sometimes you forget
that they're really good with drama -
that's why I'm so excited about the Thea
storyline I feel like she's gonna be
drama - the show in a way that we
haven't seen before it's just gonna make
things much more personal between Oliver
and Malcolm Tommy was like Oliver's
brother but Thea very literally is his
sister so it's a family affair between
the three of them now that level of
intimacy is part of the reason why Slade
was such an effective villain last year
because he and Oliver had such a close
relationship either way next week is
gonna be a very Merlin heavy storyline
so look forward to seeing a ton of John
Barrowman
and a ton of Willa Holland kicking butt
so I'll post that video after the
episode airs next week be sure to
subscribe to get it all so big news
about the DC movie universe so here's
the schedule that Warner Brothers has
announced really the big talk is that
the movies are gonna completely be
separate from the TV show but they
announced that at Comic Con I feel like
people just forgot that
so here the movies Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice 2016 then the Suicide
Squad movie directed by David Ayer also
in 2016 then there's the Wonder Woman
standalone movie that's going to be in
2017 then Justice League part 1
directed by Zack Snyder obviously
that'll be like spring summer 20
then there's a flash standalone movie
starring Ezra Miller in 2018 that caused
a little bit of controversy this morning
just because you know the Grant Gustin
flash show just started and everyone
loves him so there's a little bit of
drama because Ezra Miller is also
playing the Barry Allen flash and people
feel like it's a bit of a missed
opportunity they could have done like an
african-american Wally West and not
stepped on the toes of the TV show so
then we have Aquaman starring Jason
Momoa and that's also a 20-18 later in
2018 I feel like that's the worst kept
secret ever like anyone with a pulse
probably knew that Jason Momoa is gonna
be Aquaman then there's the Shazam movie
in 2019 obviously now we know that the
rock is gonna be playing Black Adam then
later in 2019
there's Justice League part two I don't
know how you guys feel about them
splitting movies into two parts I'll
explain why that's happening in a second
but then after that is cyborg that's ray
Fisher in 2020 then Green Lantern later
in 2020 a lot of this got announced
during Comic Con they just didn't
confirm the dates just to answer the
two-part Justice League WTF stuff the
reason they're probably splitting it
into two parts is because they want to
spend those first two hours putting the
team together in the second to defeating
whatever the big villain is there is a
little bit of news on the Suicide Squad
movie - they're considering Tom Hardy
for one of the roles I know a lot of you
asked about Manu Bennett being in it you
know like the TV show version of The
Suicide Squad obviously the film people
don't care about any of the TV show
people like there's no way Stephen Amell
is gonna get a cameo in Justice League
and obviously Grant Gustin totally not
gonna be in that flash movie it is a bit
of a bummer that they're not doing all
that crossover stuff but honestly I
don't think it's gonna be terrible
it'll just require a little bit of
explaining right now click here for my
flash episode 2 video and click here for
my arrow episode 1 video thank you so
much for watching so let's all high five
and just have a good cry for caity lotz
you will be missed
you